[Music]
[Music]
welcome to long crime daily i'm
angenette levy in for brian buckmeyer
and with me as always is co-host terry
austin we begin tonight with the trial
of a former police captain accused of
murder in a movie theater a jury of six
people reaches a verdict after only
three hours of deliberation now this
case you'll recall dates all the way
back to 2014 when the defendant curtis
reeves shot and killed chad olson at a
pasco county florida movie theater
reeves defense team says olson was on
his cell phone during movie theater
previews after reeves reported olson to
management a fight broke out reeves says
olson threw a cell phone at him and that
he feared for his life on the stand he
testified it was the quote end of the
line for me saying olson was coming at
him with rage that's when reeves shot
olson claiming it was self-defense since
the 2014 shooting and a failed stand
your ground hearing in 2017 reeves has
been on house arrest at about 9 p.m last
friday night the jury returned a
surprising verdict
state of florida versus curtis judson
reeves count one murder in the second
degree verdict we the jury finds as
follows
the defendant is not guilty count two
aggravated battery
verdict we the jury finds as follows
the defendant is not guilty
and we're joined by co-host terry austin
of course and legal analyst mike
corebonick's legal analyst for law and
crime network of course mike i'll start
with you on this one a lot of people
thought this was going to be a guilty
verdict what do you think led to an
acquittal on both counts a lot of people
were very surprised by this
well i'm one of those a lot of people to
be quite frank with you in this matter i
i was very shocked by the verdict in
this matter but when you review it and
look at it i think there were certain
things that played to the defense's
favor in this matter mainly that he
didn't really react immediately he
actually went to
the
management of the movie theater and
reported what was going wrong
then he had another confrontation and i
think that
by putting him on the stand which i
usually hardly ever agree with but here
we had a former police chief who was
trained how to testify and i think when
they put on to the fact that he
had warned him not to uh to put his
phone to put the phone away and then
went and reported it and then was
confronted that at that point with his
age he felt he was at a serious risk and
didn't have a time to say can i fight
this guy and he just went to what he was
trained for and that was his gun and
with the jury of six people it looked
like it carried the day beyond the
reasonable doubt but it's shocking to me
mike you brought up a great point about
curtis reeves testifying and terry i'm
wondering what you think about that do
you think that made all of the
difference in this case because as mike
referenced these police officers and
this was a guy who was a police officer
for more than 20 years they are trained
to testify and he's had since 2014
to think a lot about this
well that's right usually it's not a
good idea to take the stand i agree with
both of you actually because you're
subject to cross-examination but here we
have someone who's trained to talk on
the stand and he had an opportunity here
to explain his mindset what was going
through his mind why was he afraid that
there might be death or serious bodily
injury so i think he explained himself
very well i too was shocked but
absolutely the jury believed him i think
whether or not he got on that stand
very interesting take from both of you
curtis reeves is a free man he can do
whatever he wishes from now on now on to
kentucky and that is where former
louisville metro police officer brett
hankinson is a as expected rather to
take the stand this week he is facing
charges in connection to the death of
brianna taylor during the execution of a
search warrant back in 2020. now
hankerson is not charged with taylor's
death but instead faces charges of
wanton endangerment for firing shots
through taylor's apartment and into a
unit neighboring hers in march 2020
officers executed a no-knock warrant on
taylor's apartment her boyfriend
believing the officers were intruders
fired at them the officers shot back and
taylor was killed in the crossfire
last week taylor's sister and mother
were both separately asked to leave the
courtroom for wearing a shirt and a
jacket depicting taylor's face while
taylor's sister was just asked to change
her shirt taylor's mother was escorted
out of the courthouse law and crime
daily host brian buckmeyer sat down with
taylor's mother who says she found the
incident disrespectful but is more
concerned with the court proceedings
for us it's not about what's happening
in the courtroom it's more about what's
not happening right
nothing about this case has to do with
what happened to brianna taylor but
although i would love that i simply
would much rather be able to sit in the
courtroom instead of having to deal with
this issue every day and watch people be
escorted out i think that um
it will come off as chaos and and we
don't want that either you know we want
to be able to get through this and
hopefully have a conviction for
what little charge this is
on monday a hearing was held outside the
presence of the jurors to discuss the
other two officers involved in this case
if they are called to the stand both
officers plan to invoke their fifth
amendment right to not testify and to
not incriminate themselves court is
expected to resume on tuesday morning
with more testimony and just after
disgraced real estate heir robert durst
murder conviction was vacated in the
last several days we are now hearing
from the jurors who sat through his
trial and found him guilty of murdering
susan berman now in september of last
year durst was found guilty of that
murder of berman the trial which
stretched on for months between 2020 and
2021 was followed closely by a panel of
23 people 12 regular jurors and then 11
alternates when durst died in january of
this year he was appealing the guilty
verdict handed down by the jury
according to california state law
because an appeal was in the process at
the time of durst's death the conviction
must be vacated monday morning we spoke
with carrie antholous host of the jury
duty podcast that he takes a deeper look
at the jury who served under durst trial
he explained how two jurors carmen
kleckata and john okanachi feel about
the vacated conviction
john was
philosophical about it ultimately carmen
i think was as well but carmen expressed
substantially more regret that the court
system uh in california and in many
other jurisdictions
essentially throws out a conviction if
the
uh if the case is pending appeal when a
person dies
i also spoke with john lewin the
prosecutor about it and john
also was pretty philosophical about it
um but he also
indicated that there are arguments to
make for
allowing a a conviction to stand once
someone dies
still ahead on law and crime daily a
second day of evidentiary hearings begin
as convicted killer scott peterson asks
for a new trial in the death of his wife
lacey and their unborn son connor but
first the disappearance of harmony
montgomery new details are released in a
new hampshire state investigation we
will have the very latest straight ahead
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back a report released by new
hampshire's governor found that there
were missed opportunities to help a
little girl named harmony montgomery who
hasn't been seen in more than two years
harmony's father adam montgomery is in
jail right now accused of assaulting her
by hitting her in the eye and giving her
a black eye back in 2019 and it's
apparent from this investigation that
that black eye is included in this
report about how children's services
handled harmony's case
governor chris sununu released this
update on the handling of harmony
montgomery's case by new hampshire's
department of children youth and
families an anonymous tip in july of
2019 led caseworkers to harmony and her
family the report says after three home
visits it was determined that harmony
seemed happy and that the black eye
occurred as the result of horseplay with
a lightsaber harmony's father adam
montgomery is now charged with giving
harmony that black eye i think there's a
lot that needs to be done at the state
level in massachusetts and new hampshire
but also at the federal level and you
know right now our focus is trying to
find harmony blair miller is a
washington-based news correspondent he
and his husband adopted harmony's
younger brother jamison he still very
much
thinks of harmony in a very positive way
you know he'll talk about her blonde
hair her blue eyes he'll be at a park
and think he sees her he'll tell his
teachers about her last week miller
posted on twitter a letter that he and
his husband wrote to adam montgomery
pleading with him to share information
with authorities about harmony's
whereabouts
this wasn't just a letter for adam this
is a letter for everyone you know
hopefully someone out there reads this
maybe it's not adam maybe it's someone
else who reads this and says
i do know something and i this is
bringing back a lot of thoughts and
memories
now also recommended in the governor's
update is a new interstate compact
that's an agreement between the state of
new hampshire and other states he wants
a new agreement drafted so that in the
future these cases are handled more
carefully there had been some type of
home study
required for harmony to be moved from
the custody of her mother in
massachusetts to new hampshire but it
was determined that that home study
never occurred so it's just a really sad
awful case mike and terry this is a case
that's really bothered me as a mom terry
i know you're a mom too
it's really sad and horrible to wonder
about how a child could be missing for
more than two years and nobody nobody
notices so terry i'll start with you um
you know it seems like a lot of people
are pointing the finger at one another
all of these different adults dad
pointing the finger at mom mom pointing
the finger at dad
so you know is there a chance that
nobody is ever held accountable for what
happened to harmony
i mean sadly angenette it is a chance
that that could possibly happen i mean
kayla the stepmom is saying she thought
that adam the father took the child back
to her mother then the mother is saying
she thought the child was with the
father and the father is saying well i
took her back to her mother so they are
literally pointing fingers at each other
and i think that the entire system has
failed this young child and hopefully we
will see charges beyond the welfare
fraud and beyond other charges that
don't relate to harmony
mike this case really makes me wonder
just how many children out there are
falling through the cracks i i heaven
forbid there's another harmony
montgomery out there so what kind of
changes can new hampshire and other
states make and can some federal
legislation actually be drafted to
prevent this type of thing in the
future well it's always easy to talk
about theories and what could and should
be done and things of that nature i
think one of the things that are most
important is that you really have to
start for these child protective
services things of that nature with the
training of those agents who work for
those agencies meaning that to make sure
that their initial investigations are
checked upon followed up upon it's very
difficult for me to hear this as a
criminal defense lawyer because i have
seen just the opposite some in many
occasions where there are allegations
that are not really that strong that
that need some further investigation yet
they rush to conclusions here it looks
like this just totally fell off the
radar and it's very disturbing so i
think you've got to start from square
one before you get to all the politics
of it by just better training with the
investigators
and let's hope they find harmony
sooner rather than later we are all
hoping the best for that little girl
well coming up on law and crime daily we
move on to ohio where a former icu
doctor is accused of murdering 14 of his
patients he is on trial right now plus
nearly 20 years after the murder of his
wife lacey and unborn son connor could
scott peterson get a new trial that's
still ahead on law and crime daily
[Music]
scott peterson is back in a california
courtroom as the second day of
evidentiary hearings as he asks for a
new trial get underway on the stand a
juror from peterson's first trial she's
been dread strawberry shortcake for many
years she's testifying about letters
that she wrote to scott peterson after
he went to prison now peterson's defense
attorneys are arguing that he deserves a
new trial based on juror misconduct this
stems from juror 7 in peterson's 2004
trial defense attorneys say rachelle
neese did not disclose a past abusive
relationship while she was pregnant
niece who took the stand on friday and
again monday was granted immunity in
exchange for her testimony nearly 20
years ago niece was part of the jury
that convicted peterson in the deaths of
his 27 year old wife lacey and their
unborn son connor
during monday's testimony niece said she
exchanged letters with peterson
following the guilty verdict where she
referred to peterson's unborn child as
quote little man she says peterson
maintained he did not kill his wife or
child defense attorneys also read
excerpts from the book titled we the
jury co-authored by nice and several
other jurors after peterson's conviction
peterson was originally sentenced to
death in the case but was later
re-sentenced to life in prison after the
california supreme court said his death
sentence should be overturned now terry
i'll start with you on this one we've
discussed this case many times
peterson's death sentence as i mentioned
had been vacated and now we're on to
issues of jury selection and possible
juror misconduct this is really the only
outstanding issue he has left to argue
so how do we improve the jury selection
process to keep these types of things
from happening again
well you know obviously every defendant
has a sixth amendment right to a jury of
your peers but here i think we need to
have better voir dear obviously lawyers
can ask questions but we should really
have more ramifications if those
questions are not answered correctly and
those ramifications would be everything
from contempt of court to paying fines
to being in prison and i also think we
need more rules you shouldn't be able to
write a book and make money i think that
gives the wrong incentives to a jury
they should just go in to try to decide
the case period end of story
and mike you know she's known as
strawberry shortcake you saw the wild
red hair she had during the trial
so that's why people call her that it's
not a derisive thing but we know that
this is uh she's really the big witness
in this case she's the star of the show
so
what could what impact could other
witnesses possibly have on the outcome
i i really don't know if they could have
much but it's funny when you said star
of the show because that's the problem
here getting back to what terry said is
you shouldn't be allowed to publicize
your jury duty you should only be
allowed to speak it for educational
purposes and things of that nature but
you shouldn't be allowed to profit from
it
interesting take from both of you all
right
when we come back we're going to bring
you up to speed on the case of a former
icu doctor in the state of ohio accused
of murdering his patients his name is
william husell and a fellow icu doctor
is called to the stand to testify
against him as husel has tried on 14
counts of murder
[Music]
welcome back and we're going on to ohio
now where a former icu doctor is accused
of murdering more than 14 or murdering
14 of his patients in the icu where he
worked now so far jurors have heard
testimony in the case of dr william
husel from a nurse a physician and
several pharmacists who worked at mount
carmel hospital in columbus ohio on
monday prosecutors called dr wes ely a
professor of medicine at vanderbilt
university he testified about specifics
involving the drug fentanyl including
the impacts it can have and the safety
of using that medication he also told
the jury the highest dosage of morphine
he had ever given a patient was 200
micrograms prosecutors say husel gave
his patients 600 to 2 000 micrograms at
a time they say in
and that in turn ended up killing them
the doctor was asked specifically about
one patient receiving a dosage
of a thousand micrograms of fentanyl
before she died
it's unclear from looking at these
medical records how long she would live
she could live for days she could live
for maybe weeks
we don't know that
and when she was given a thousand
micrograms of fentanyl
she only lived for eight minutes
and i think it's because her brain was
completely shut off from delivering any
more breathing
by this
what was what i deem a lethal dose of
the medication and i think it was
unethical to give her a thousand
micrograms of fentanyl when we did not
know how long her natural life would lit
would would lead
and i think that we assured that she
would not live
by giving that dose which to me is the
cause of her death
mike do you think the jury at this point
is likely convinced convinced that we
know the cause of the death but they
just have to determine what was husel's
intent and administering that amount of
fentanyl or morphine
i think that's a very interesting
question it's going to be very
interesting from the jury because this
is a trial where they've got to go
through two levels to decide where to go
next first they've got to see in the
profession did he violate professional
ethics then based on that to decide if
he violated the law very unusual very
interesting
terry if huesel is convicted on the
murder counts that's a life sentence 15
years to life do you think this will
impact at all comfort care provided to
patients in the u.s
i absolutely think it's going to impact
physicians they're going to be thinking
twice now about whether or not to offer
comfort care this is an assisted suicide
we've seen those types of cases before
this is a physician who is looking at a
patient who is near the end of their
life and they are thinking you might be
in pain remember dr hussell had a
patient one of his first patients was in
pain right before she died and he saw
her suffer since that time at least
according to the defense he has been
trying to give this comfort care to his
patients as they are nearing death if we
see a conviction here and it would be a
conviction of murder these physicians
are going to think twice before offering
comfort care they're going to want
someone to sign a form they're going to
not only follow these protocols that
mike is talking about but they're going
to be even more careful to make sure
everybody is on board making sure the
pharmacist has seen what was needed as
far as giving that care was concerned so
i think we're going to see people being
far more stricter
well mike corbonix thanks for being with
us today and terry thanks to you as
always and thank you for being with us
you've been watching law and crime daily
and we'll see you next time as we
continue to discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you